hello everyone and welcome back to this
short series where we're going to show a
couple of games by the candidates where
they faced magnus carlsen in classical
chess uh and this is uh this is a
beautiful game from 2008 so 14 years ago
uh it was played in the alinar's
tournament were basically morally
illinois it was uh half of the
tournament was played in morality half
was played in linares uh where rajab uh
faces magnus carlsen now it's uh
you might say okay but that was so long
ago surely the games were not uh you
know up to today's standard uh this game
uh was very much up to today's standard
as you'll see it's simply brilliant and
uh well that that is required when you
wanna uh take down a player like magnus
even though uh this was um
in the days of vichy and it was in fact
vishwanathan anand who won this
tournament uh half a point the head of
magnus carlsen uh still the game is uh
brilliant and you guys will enjoy this
one so rajab has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 we have e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and the bishop to b5 deruy
lopez is on the board and we have knight
to f6 by magnus so young but playing the
berlin defense we have d3 uh bishop to
c5 ending now c3 both players cancel and
now uh you can see that okay maybe it
comes as a surprise but also uh it's
2008 the magnus is about 16 years old
[Music]
the the most common moves now are d6 and
rook t8 but magnus just strikes in the
center right away with the d5 pawn going
all the way and now it's just a very
sharp game so knight b to d2 we have d
captures on e4 and now there are some
games where d characters and e4 was
played but magnus plays uh sorry um our
java plays knight captures on e4 uh and
it is now uh already as of movie 8 that
we have a completely new game uh so uh
surprising magnus a little bit with this
idea so magnus says okay i'm going to
capture the knight at a job of happily
offers a queen trade and now magnus
plays queen to f6 he wants to put
pressure under the job of
king side bishop is coming to g4 and
then you can activate your rooks maybe
with rook to d8 and rook to e8 so here
queen e2 uh we have bishop to g4 and now
arjav says all right h3 let's trade
queens this way so okay bishop captures
queen captures and queen captures uh g
captures and this is the position that
you get uh now of course you don't want
to allow bishop captures on c6 so magnus
goes knight to the e7 and now pawn to f4
getting rid of the double death pawn uh
c6 chasing the bishop away bishop to c4
and now he captures an f4 now we bishop
captures on f4 and the knight the g6
going after jabba's bishop here bishop
to g3 and the rook f to e8 putting
pressure on the pawn now rook after e1
and now rook a to d8 and you can see
that black has no problems in this line
the rooks are now uh nicely placed on
the dnd file rajab does the same rook to
d1 and now magnus trades and uh well
grabs the e4 pawn here
magnus has to figure out why arajabov is
offering a pawn obviously it's for
activity but
is it is it safe to do that
you could also maybe just start playing
h5 h4 maybe king of fate try to bring
the king
closer to the center of the board but he
accepts the challenge rook captures on
the one we rook captures and now rook
captures an e4 grabbing a pawn
threatening the bishop here now comes
rook to d8 with check knight to f8 and
now bishop to d3 attacking the rook and
now rookie one check we have king to g
to end pawn to a5 you don't have to
worry about the bishop captures on h7 uh
because even if king captures you can't
capture the knight the knight is
defended by the bishop so in case you
were wondering about that so here rook
e8 arjavo goes after the a pawn and now
rook to d1 attacking the bishop and now
bishop to c4 now if you trade uh if you
play bishop cap a rook captures an a5
with the idea that okay i just grab a
pawn and we trade bishop's uh there's
the uh so sorry there's b6 um
i guess b4 is just always in my head uh
but yeah b6 just uh defends the bishop
attacks the rook and next move you can
just capture the bishop if bishop c2 we
just play rook d2 no problem so after
rook to d1 we have bishop to c4 uh by
tamer and now comes bishop to b6 here
pawn to b6 would be safer but magnus
plays bishop to b6 and this is what
allows our job off to really make uh
make his next a couple of moves count he
plays rook to b8 goes after the b7 pawn
and okay magnus brings the rogue back
rook to d7 defends the pawn and now
bishop to a6 now the problem is if
b captures an a6 which is kind of uh
there really aren't all that many better
moves uh uh carlson's the pawn structure
on the queen side will be completely
shattered so okay b captures on a6 rook
captures and b6 and uh all of these
pawns are incredibly weak we have f6 uh
and rook captures on a6 we have rook to
d2 magnus goes after the b2 pawn and now
again uh the strongest move ever that is
pawn to b4
uh so the problem is if you capture on
eight to now uh we're just gonna play
real captures on a5 or for a rook trade
and there's really not all that much you
can play you can't trade rooks because
our past a pawn will be unstoppable if
you go here we just defend the c pawn go
after this pawn we're going to have two
connected pass pawns on the queen side
this will be completely winning for uh
uh for for rajavo so here a captures on
b4 instead uh we have c captures and now
rook to b2 it seems that magnus is able
to stop the two pawns uh bishop to d6 uh
now defending the pawn and also putting
pressure on f8 if you allow rook to a8
it's game over so knight to e6 and now
pawn to a4 getting rid of the target
here and now now you are ready to start
pushing your past a pawn so here rook to
c2 and we have pawn to a5 king to f7
magnus starts bringing the king into the
game now comes bishop the c5 a very nice
idea that prevents the rook from moving
because okay you can't capture the pawn
right away uh
but for example if knight captures we're
going to play rook captures on c6 and
now you can't move the knight so we're
gonna probably most likely win this with
white so instead a magnus finds a knight
to a f4 with check king to f3 and now
knight to d5 uh saying that all right uh
now
again you can't really play this if you
play rook captures on c6 i can always
play knight captures on b4
but there is one move that magnus missed
here and it is the one that rachabov
played basically the only move that wins
the game for him uh feel free to pause
the video here and try to spot this
brilliancy while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
tricky idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to b6 that's the move we offer the rook
and we move the rook away from the a
file uh with uh well
with such elegance i would say
because now we're just gonna play rook
b7 with check so we're gonna win the
seventh rank with tempo we're gonna play
pawn to a6 pawn to a7 and then our
position will be completely winning and
even if you capture the rook just eight
captures and b6 there's no stopping the
pawn you can play rook to d2 b7 rook to
d8 it seems like we've stopped the pawn
but just bishop a7 next move we win the
rook it's a game over so after rook to
b6 we have rook to c4 by magnus now
comes rook to b7 this comes with check
that's also a big problem
king to g6 now pawn to a6 rook to c3
check
king to g2 and now knight to f4 with
check and here
another great position where i could ask
you to pause the video and i in fact i
will ask you to pause the video here
there are many possible squares you can
go to with the king but only one is
winning so pretty sure you know which
one it is but just in case uh once again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only winning move for uh
rajabov while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not playing king
f1 that's just silly
or king h2 or king h1 but for those of
you who found king the g1 uh
congratulations you are a true master of
not blundering a completely winning game
so here king the g1 and now there is
really nothing more to be done here of
course king f1 you can see that it's
mate in one rook to c1 because the
knight covers these two squares and if
you go king to h1 or h2 you just allow
silly perpetuals uh everywhere just rook
captures an h3 check king g1 knight to
check and now after knight aking to f1
we're just going to repeat knight f4 now
we're again threatening checkmate with
rook to h1 as g2 and d2 are covered and
there is nothing if you go k1 you try to
escape with your king now uh you you
will not be able to do it knight e3
checking e2 knight captures here and
rook to a3 will come just in time
regardless of whether you capture on b
or not
rook day
3 just prevents the the pawn from doing
anything you can push the a7 but it's
never coming to a8 that's the problem
so the only move that wins is king to g1
i have no doubt all of you found this uh
and now we have knight captures on h3
with czech king to h2 now there are no
more checks knight to f4 and here not
even allowing uh some trickery would
work to h3 raja will just played bishop
to e3 and he was in this position on mu
43 that uh magnus calls and resigned in
the game and a brilliant brilliant
victory in this uh hard played and hard
fought end game for for timur ajabov and
now you resign here because obviously
after rook to a3 we're going to push the
pawn to a7 and now it's defended by the
bishop so there's really
no hope here there are some tricks of
course knight d5 we're still going to
save the bishop bishop c5 and if king f5
now we just play rook to b8 and our pawn
will get promoted if knight c7 the guard
the a8 square we're just gonna play rook
c8 kick away the knight and okay knight
b5 let's say we're gonna promote the
queen uh rook captures rook captures and
now we are up a full rook of course
completely winning for rajabov so after
bishop to e3 magnus resigned and a
spectacular win for for timor ajabov in
this brilliant brilliant game from 2008
in the morelia linares tournament and if
you guys are interested about the
standings these are the standings of uh
of this event you can see it was won by
viswanathan and current world champion
or rather current world champion in 2008
second place magnus carlson only half a
point behind behind anand you can see
that um he has three losses one of them
being this game against the job of
within and a half to paulov and darunian
with seven are a job of evan chukwu with
six and a half and with five and a half
peter lehko and alexey shiroff
uh so that's the game a little bit of
history for you guys to enjoy and we are
continuing our series of how our players
fared against uh magnus in their best
best classical games uh so yeah once
again hope you guys uh enjoyed it uh i
would um i would like to thank martin
your paparik
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos uh here thank you all
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of their best
games against the world champion
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course uh nothing
else is happening in the chess world as
we are waiting for the candidates
tournament starts on june 16th but the
first game is on the 17th so in case you
missed that
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day